i was uh taking my dog for a walk i have
two dogs but uh the other one's quite
old whenever i said you want to take a
walk he says go [ __ ] yourself
yeah very and he says it in perfect
english might just not want to be seen
with you probably but then the other
younger dog is always cool to go with me
so we went on this hike up through will
rogers uh national park and was really
nice we're having this nice walk
and we stop and i bring water with me so
the dog can drink plenty of water and
this guy recognized me he came up to me
and he said uh oh hey conan could you
help me out i'm about to propose
to my girlfriend whoa and i didn't know
what what part i was gonna play and he
said can you
videotape it for me
and what handed me his phone he handed
me his phone which was already set to
video
you are the last person why what are you
saying
why because i feel like you
would mess it up no i'm not saying that
to your feelings oh is there another way
that can be taken i don't know i feel
like you would just forget to press the
red button no it was going i've checked
to make sure that it was going he didn't
trust me either clearly because he
started it and handed it to me so he has
video of me saying um and i think and
then the first thing i said to him is i
looked at him and i saw that his
girlfriend was up the trail just a
little bit chatting with someone else
and
i said are we sure about this
oh because i just thought you know guide
a guy you just want to say like and it
was kind of joking but i'm like are you
sure about this and he went yes i'm sure
then i realized why did i say that yeah
because what about you men are we sure
about this me as videographer no you
know no stop would you guys get off that
for a second i know how to aim something
i can aim something it's already running
all right that's that's that's not and
that's not a big claim but let's just
shut up about the
don't phones just explode when you hold
them because they know you're so stupid
so no i um
they do not
okay several did but most don't
so
i said was sure about this and he went
yep then i immediately was like
self-conscious cause um i'm thinking why
did i say that i'm gonna mess this up um
sorry no
shut up
but then i realized like that's a rude
like what if he had said gee i don't
know
no one's asked me that yet i might have
he was the surest young man i've ever
seen and no judgment though um
i
shut up so
he goes up
and he starts first of all he takes out
uh he has a backpack he goes up to his
girlfriend and he's like hold on a
second she's like what's going on he
takes out of his backpack
he takes a knee pad straps it to his
knee yes
and then he kneels hence the knee pad in
the dirt and
she's like what's happening and then he
takes out the box and then she puts her
hands up to her mouth and she's
starts like i think crying and you're
standing there i'm saying that now
listen i'm a distance away and i didn't
want to blow it if i if i go rushing up
and i'm shooting she's going to know
something's happening so i'm kind of far
away
not doing a pinch zoom or anything like
that hold on but then i start i start
and you know what i don't know to do the
pinch zoom okay okay and guess what i
don't you're right i don't know to do
the pinch zoom so what i do
is i creep up
and i'm moving closer and closer and
closer as he's proposing
and then there's a tree and the friend
who's there is also shooting it
and
the girlfriend's face is blocked and so
i think i should move around for a
different angle i'm actually putting
some thought into this huh so i come up
coming around the tree and then i get
this like nice side shot
and you know you can see that she says
yes and everything and then we're done
and
they turn to me and they go thank you
and i stop it
and then i realize that the way i've
shot it it was me being really
conscientious about you know let's get
in close let's move around the tree it's
the point of view
of a murderer yeah this is who's
chilling from halloween the opening
scene of any horror movie
is a
young man and a young woman
kissing and creepo is moving up
and then moves around a tree to the side
and then pushes in on them and comes in
for the kill so their proposal video
is like by wes craven you know oh man
and so um yeah this is crazy because you
know what just happened to me i'm not
even joking at halloween we are in south
pasadena where the literally the michael
myers house is the house from halloween
and we walk by and two people a guy
proposes to his wife on the steps of the
michael myers house and i started
videoing it and gave it to them and i
shot it for them what was he wearing oh
wait oh wait a minute wait a minute same
guy who's just going around following
and he's a super fan of this text and
he's just finding all of you and he's
like uh i need you to film me proposing
to my girlfriend and is there anything
wait a minute
so you were filming them without even
being asked i was asked to do it you're
a creep you're a no no you're behind the
tree please that's just did they ask you
or not to shoot it no but there was
access
that is a secret moment both of you shut
your mouths and listen to me okay this
is the angriest we've all ever been at
each other there's a lot of shut up you
shut up
shut up bro i'll kill you quiet you'll
stick around thank you shut up okay
all right this was at halloween so there
was a crowd of people at this house
everybody was filming it like it was it
was a celebration it was oh man it's you
know that's it's like a mecca at
halloween where everybody goes there
that likes the movie halloween yeah well
anyway i just want to say to that couple
their names are paula and hugh
and they just got engaged uh at will
rogers state park and i was their
videographer
i apologize
that when you play the video plo please
do this when when you whenever you do
look at that video put scary music to it
it's gonna look fantastic because i
didn't mean to do that but it really
does i think you should definitely put
scary
horror movie to it as i'm creeping up on
you guys and that by the way that's a
service i do provide you can call me
anytime
and and hunt me down and i will i will
provide that service